magdalena siaudeau nick notre envoyé
spécial à la frontière polonaise à
l'afflux des réfugiés continue
oui je suis dans un point d'accueil 1
entre 9 en fait tous ancrés en pologne
il ya toujours des ukrainiens qui vient
juste à côté il ya un petit ukrainien
qui est à côté c'est pour ça que je
serais un tout petit peu parce qu'il va
faire en tuerie et mais a toujours des
femmes des enfants qu'ils arrivent dont
qui cherchent un refuge un peu de
tranquillité
après tout ce qui se passe est que ce
qui se passe en ukraine ils ont dû
laisser leur papa leurs partenaires en
ukraine parce que les hommes entre 18 et
60 ans ils peuvent pas partir ils
peuvent pas aller
peut pas partir il peut parler à
l'étranger a donc tout ce que ce que
tous les gens qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est surtout des personnes âgées les
mamans des jeunes mamans et des enfants
et quel est l'accueil prévu par la
pologne
le gouvernement déjà bien faciliter le
passage pour les ukraniens donc il faut
qu'il se présente avec un papier qui
peut le à densifier ça doit pas être
forcément mon passeport biométrique en
avant maintenant même les enfants qui
n'ont pas de passeport ils ont un
certificat de naissance ils peuvent
passer la frontière il vient juste le
gouvernement vient juste d'annoncer que
le jeu crânien peuvent prendre le train
gratuitement pour se déplacer en pologne
il ya ici beaucoup de volontaires qui
vient le chercher gratuitement aussi et
dans le point d'accueil y trouve la
nourriture il y a toujours quelque chose
à boire un endroit où ils peuvent dormir
au chaud à tranquille et à une med mais
des aides médicales et psychologiques
aussi pour ce qu' ils ont besoin merci
magdalena tonique merci pour vos
précisions